Prof: Okay let's get
started.
It occurred to me over the
break that Goldman Sachs gets
some bad press.
Is there--has anybody read the
piece in Rolling Stone?
Okay can--these--where are the
hand microphones?
Do we have the hand microphones?
Student:  Yeah,
Matt Taibi of Rolling Stone
called Goldman Sachs a--
I might get this quote wrong,
but it's something along the
lines of "A great vampire
squid relentlessly jamming its
blood funnel into anything that
smells like money."
Prof: I think that's an
exact quote.
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: We should have
tried that out on Paolo.
Now it also reminds me of the
passage in Richard Posner's
book,
to the effect that we can no
more blame the financiers for
the wreckage of the credit
markets than we could blame a
lion for eating a zebra,
and there's an odd
discontinuity here.
When you look at Goldman Sachs
internally, through the eyes of
one of its very senior partners,
the ethical component is big.
There's a huge component about
integrity and meeting one's
obligations and delivering the
highest quality product on the
market,
and at the same time,
Goldman is vulnerable to the
view that it took inordinate
advantage of the taxpayers in
the recent debacle.
Now how would they defend
themselves?
They would say--one thing they
would say is,
"We didn't want to take
the money.
Hank Paulson told us we had to
take the money,"
because the stigma which would
otherwise fall on the banks
which took the money would cause
further disruption and meltdown;
that's one thing they would say.
Another thing--well,
have you noticed what they're
doing to--in the way of
charitable activities just
lately?
Anybody notice the announcement?
$500 million dollars in help to
10,000 small businesses.
Does that strike you as a big
gesture or a little gesture?
Tal, what do you think?
Student:  Well as a
percent of their revenues,
profits, or even just the
amount they pay out in bonuses
every year,
I would say that's a very
little gesture.
Prof: That's a very
I agree.
From a public relations point
of view, if they multiplied it
by ten so it's five billion,
would it do them more good?
Them, not the world,
not the country,
them.
Student:  I think that
adding a couple more zeroes
would probably make a bit of a
difference in public opinion,
but I don't know if it would
fully make up for the perceived
damage that they caused in the
public's consciousness.
Prof: Okay so my own
intuition is that it wouldn't do
them a lot of good.
That the public doesn't think
quantitatively,
some opinion leaders do,
but most people $500 million
sounds like an awful lot of
money and five billion doesn't
sound like ten times as much,
so they're probably not far off
in the number they chose if the
object is public relations,
which I think it is.
How many--are there people here
who think that the government
ought to compel them to give
back a bigger chunk of capital,
put it out there in some
charitable way or give it back
to the taxpayers.
Anybody of that view?
Okay so you're unanimous which
is rare in a group this size.
Does that mean that you think
there's no ought to it,
or does it mean that the
process by which the government
would do that strikes you as not
a good one?
Who's got a--rescue me here
guys I'm drowning.
Student:  There is a big
difference between what you
should do and what the
government can make you do.
I don't think that there's any
reason any large corporation
should be forced to donate to
charity,
unless it's like a sort of ad
hoc tax randomly applied to
them,
and that seems like a
>
and we don't want to go there.
Prof: Okay so it
probably would violate the
Constitution if we created The
Goldman Sachs Retribution Act.
I agree with that.
So we're coming to the end of
the course,
and what I want to do is today
to add one more case,
one which allows us to look at
the interface between capital,
the environment,
and government in the TXU
v.
EDF case which you've
all looked at and which is
structured so that you could
invest a whole week in it if you
were willing to trace out every
strand in the web page.
Then on Wednesday I'm going to
do a recap of the course,
as if on a motorcycle,
and finish with a central case
which will form the basis for
your final exam essay,
and since it's going to count
for 70% of the final,
I'm sure we'll have 100%
attendance during the last
twenty minutes of class,
and I'll give you the reading
assignment in advance.
It is the--Leasing the Rain,
it's the--
the reading is the William
Finnegan piece from The New
Yorker about the
privatization of the water
supply of Cochabamba,
Bolivia by an American
corporation known as Bechtel.
And the essay question--I'll
formulate it at the end of class
Wednesday,
asks you to work through that
story as somebody who has
learned something about
capitalism in this course.
Okay so now,
marrying the devil and the one
difficulty with this case is
that it's full of acronyms,
and these are the most
important, or most immediately
important of the acronyms,
and can anybody here quickly
recite the full names of every
one of these?
Who wants to be a show off?
I'm sure there are fifty people
who can do it.
Okay I'll--let's put them into
three bins.
This is the most obscure,
Texas Climate Initiative,
and Jim Marsden who is the
video star of the case is
president of that,
and he is the regional head of
EDF,
The Environmental Defense Fund
for Texas,
and The Natural Resources
Defense Council is a--
is parallel to the EDF;
a little harder edge and
important--then in the gray box
in the middle we have the target
firms in the private equity
takeover.
It's just one firm really,
it's TXU, but the focus
strategically is on TXU plus.
It is on the expanded
generation capacity that TXU has
announced,
and that expanded generation
capacity is on the lower edge
from an environmental point of
view.
It relies on conventional
technology,
which no one thought at the
time, was the best available
technology for coal-fired
generation of electric current.
While we're at it,
the parts of an electric
utility company are three:
generation, transmission,
and sales or distribution.
Transmission is the long lines,
and distribution is the last
mile of lines,
and the financial connection,
the contractual connection with
the customer.
Then on the right we've got KKR
and TPG and these are both large
and very aggressive private
equity firms.
KKR is most famous for the
Reynolds/Nabisco,
RJR Nabisco takeover,
which is characterized at
length in Barbarians at the
Gate, and Texas Pacific is
actually the more interesting of
the two,
from the point of view of this
case.
Is there anybody who can snap
to an obvious conclusion about
the difference between the two?
Okay we'll draw it out in a few
minutes.
The TXU expansion 8,600
megawatts added,
that's a--just under a 50%
increment to the firm's total
generating capacity.
Ten or $11 billion dollars in
costs,
somewhere between $50 billion
and $2 billion of that are
budgeted to controls of
pollution,
and it's pretty murky in the
case and pretty murky in fact
just how much of it--
how much of the capital can be
construed as pollution control.
They promise a 20% cut in
emissions--what do they mean by
that?
Who thought that one through?
20% cut in emissions,
we're going to add 47% to our
total generating capacity,
and we're going to cut
emissions by 20%,
what exactly is the claim?
Does it mean--yes.
Student:  I'm not sure
what TXU promised exactly,
but there are two ways you can
do that.
You can artificially--you can
buy carbon credits and reduce
your emissions,
like, technically on paper.
You can also retrofit some coal
plants and see--
so that emissions are kind of
sequestered underground,
like there are certain
technologies that allow you to
do that,
so that's some ways that you
can cut emissions.
Prof: Okay.
Those are both valid points,
but I'm still a little unclear
about how much soot is going to
come out the end of the pipe.
Yes.
Student:  I guess the
other potential difference is
whether the 20% cut is in total
emissions or if it's per unit
generated,
so if it's per unit generated
there would still be a larger
final percentage of emissions,
but it would be like less per
unit.
Prof: Yeah I think it
has to be normed in that way.
It has to be a unit rate of
emission so that these plants
are,
on average, quite a lot better
than the old plants,
though still not state of the
art, and the claim is that we're
going to drive the aggregate
emission rate per megawatt down
by 20%.
They're using old sites.
They plan to use old sites
where they've already got a
plant.
Anybody figure out why they
would say a thing like that?
Well--yes.
Student:  If you're
building a new site it requires
a lot more regulatory approval
to a green field site I guess.
Prof: Yeah.
A green field site,
you've got a whole round of
permitting, and there are a
couple of other advantages.
One is that the NIMBY politics,
"not in my backyard
politics,"
are over in those areas.
You've already been through it,
and if you can come back to
people and say,
"This is a less disruptive
plant than the old one,"
that's a pretty good start,
and even if people aren't much
taken by that,
if you've been--if the
management has been intelligent
they will have built a network
of local relationships,
which they would have to build
anew on a green field site.
Finally there's an
infrastructure reason,
that the transmission lines
required to transport the
current produced will already be
in place,
and that's both an economic and
a political plus.
Then at the end of this they
throw in a 10% discount to their
customers,
and that discount is a
non-sequitur in the
environmental discussion,
but it's not a non-sequitur in
the actual case,
because TXU is in trouble on
two political fronts at once.
It is a monopoly seller of
current and it has--
it is--it has wired the state
of Texas politically,
and there is a populist revolt
against that,
and the populist revolt takes
the form of criticizing the
ultimate pricing at the
household level.
Now if we look at the case from
Austin,
Texas we've got all these small
things,
upper right,
that are federal government,
and we've got all these big
things locally that are state
politics and government.
You've got Texas state
government where--how's TXU
doing with Governor Perry during
all this?
Is Perry a populist who wants
to beat up on them?
No, they own Perry.
I may overstate a little but
they pretty much own Governor
Perry.
The Texas Business for Clean
Air is a not all together
surprising alliance of business
groups which are opposed to TXU
on this,
on environmental grounds,
sometimes for self serving
business reasons and other
times,
I think, because it's what
senior management thinks is
right.
You've got Texans for Public
Justice and they're not so much
about the environment as about
the rates.
You've got a state senator
named Troy Frazier who is making
a name for himself statewide by
attacking TXU on the,
mostly on the rate side,
but he's also willing to take
up the environmental side.
You've got The Texas Climate
Initiative and the EDF,
which are closely intertwined
in the personality of Jim
Marston.
What did you think of Marston?
If you went all the way through
the case you've heard him,
I don't know,
five or seven times in video,
seem like an able guy?
Thumbs up if you think that,
thumbs down if you don't think
that.
Hmm...we've got ninety-five
abstentions.
He's an able guy,
he's a very able guy,
but he is a--he has a very soft
style of argument.
He never seems to be a jump
ahead of you in the argument.
He's also, in a very laid back
way,
asking your opinion,
as if he hadn't really figured
out where he wanted to go,
and that may be partly for our
benefit because he was working
for the school of management in
preparing for the case,
but it's also probably part of
his natural style.
PUCT, Public Utility Commission
of Texas, and Texas Commission
on Environmental Quality;
I almost missed that one myself.
These are the two principle
regulatory bodies in the case
and Association of Electric
Companies of Texas;
you can imagine who they are
and what the TXU's role is.
It's a classic interest
association and then you got
populist--[Video 20:35-22:50.]
Okay so any of you guys ever
done a protest of that type?
You just don't look like street
theatre types.
Do you think that's effective?
You're shaking your heads and I
think there are two sides to the
question.
Let's start in the negative
here.
Student:  I mean,
I just feel as though it's not
going to get the companies to
change their positions really,
so what's--I mean,
yes, it might stir up a little
public disapproval for a couple
of days,
but that's not really going to
change behavior.
Prof: Okay so as a
direct strategy for changing the
behavior of companies,
it goes nowhere.
We agree.
Is there any other way in which
it might be of service to the
cause these people are pursuing?
Here and then here.
Student:  If you can get
media coverage of it,
it tends to have a more
dramatic effect on public
opinion.
I was working on a political
campaign where we sent out
something that was short enough,
a picture in The Washington
Post, and so I at least from
personal experience,
think that it does have the
potential.
Probably not to affect the
direct response of the people
who you're calling out,
but that there can be larger
implications for how other
people view the situation.
Prof: Okay so the
clear--the media are the target
and then who would we most
likely influence with this sort
of thing?
Anybody want to elaborate
further?
Yes, Sasha.
Student:  I think what
the companies really worry about
is that they're clients are
going to be sensitive to the
negative press and change
companies.
Prof: Absolutely.
That's--TXU customer voter base
is part of this and both of
those nouns are important,
and they are both voters and
customers,
and they may not have many
places to go as customers but as
voters,
the perception within
regulatory and legislative
groups in Austin would be an
important consideration.
I personally don't think that
this kind of demonstration is
hugely effective,
but it does kind of raise the
temperature of the issue and
make it salient to decision
makers in government.
Now in--on the--if we switch
from Austin to Washington,
the actors get to be different
and the EPA,
and The Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission,
and the key people in Congress
like Henry Waxman or Senators
Bingaman and Boxer,
become big players,
and the EDF and the NRDF,
Natural Resource Defense Fund,
become well staffed.
They would each have fifty or
so staff people in Washington
and become a major presence,
and the question in front of
KKR and Texas Pacific hinges on
what?
Why do they--why are they
messing around with all these
environmental groups?
It would sound like,
from a purely economic point of
view,
to be a waste of time and yet
from an entirely rational
economic point of view,
it isn't a waste of time.
Why not?
Well let's look--let's go to
Wall Street.
The private equity business in
2007 there were 794 large
private equity transactions
during that year,
adding up to about $800
billion, so they average about
$1 billion a piece.
Explosive growth,
they're up about 450% to 500%
from 2000 to 2007,
and it's a period when capital
is abundant and cheap,
so the--it is in every sense
boom time for private equity.
The--you've got three sets of
players as seen from Wall
Street.
You've got private equity
firms, the target firms,
and the business services
organizations,
mainly investment banks which
catalyze transactions of this
kind and the takeover of TXU is
a megadeal.
It is the biggest transaction
of its kind ever so it gets a
lot of attention and offers to
be very profitable.
The institutional investors,
shown upper left in the blue
box,
are limited partners in the
funds created by organizations
like KKR and Texas Pacific,
and from their point of view,
this is one of the highest
yielding asset classes in their
portfolio,
and David Swenson,
for example of Yale,
one of the things he did with
the Yale portfolio which made it
grow so much faster after he
came then it had grown at any
time in the university's
history,
was to shift a great deal of
capital away from publicly
traded securities into private
equity funds which differ--
they differ--the biggest
difference between how well
investment companies do with
stocks and bonds on the one
side,
and private equity on the
other, is the difference between
the smart money and average
money.
In the stock market the
difference between very smart
money and fairly dumb money is a
few percentage points.
The difference in private
equity between the smartest
money and fairly dumb money is
enormous,
and so if an institutional
investor like Yale,
Harvard, or the big pension
funds, can get into private
equity with smart money,
hire smart management,
invest with people like Texas
Pacific and KKR,
the opportunity to beat the
market in a big way is a very
ripe one and that's the heart of
this deal.
Now from a sociological point
of view,
the people who run these
companies are pretty far away
from the green world,
which centers in major
metropolitan areas,
and is populated by well to do
activists,
and their 501(c)(3)
corporations,
of which the ones in play today
are examples.
Now, the Pacific Group is a
little different from KKR in its
relationship to those groups,
because it has one key player
in William Riley,
who had been the head of the
EPA before and who is agreeing,
and he gave--he gives Texas
Pacific a relationship to this
world which KKR pretty much
doesn't have.
David Bonderman,
who is one of the founders of
Texas Pacific,
is Harvard educated and kind of
part of this world.
If you begin tracking
personalities in these funds,
Frances Beinecke,
she of Yale fame,
is the head of Natural
Resources Defense Fund--
I don't know why I put C's
instead of F's on the end of
this--
the slides.
She's the head of that,
and a terrifically potent
leader,
and the reason the privileged
access to do this case came to
the Yale School of Management,
has something to do with that
particular connection.
There is a cultural divide
here, it is--
these are quite different views
of the world and if we compare
501(c)(3) corporations with
regular public or not publicly--
publicly traded or not publicly
traded corporations,
we get some sharp contrasts.
The business corporations are
pursuing profit.
The 501(c)(3)'s are pursuing a
cause.
The attitude to risk is far
more aggressive among the
businesses.
The boards are accountable to,
mainly to major investors on
the business side,
and to donors on the 501(c)(3)
side except that in the really
big old 501(c)(3)'s;
they're accountable to no one
because the donor is dead.
The Carnegie Corporation,
for example,
where my wife is a chief
investment officer,
Andrew Carnegie hasn't paid any
attention to their ledgers in
some time,
and it actually creates an
enormous amount of free play at
top management and board levels.
The management culture on the
business side is far more
aggressive than on--
among the non-profits and top
management compensation in--
particularly in private equity
is high and variable and Jim
would--
Jim pointed out to me that--Jim
Alexander pointed out to me this
morning that when I say high and
variable the variability may or
may not be well-tied to actual
performance.
You can get a lot of
compensation for just sitting in
the right chair during a bull
market and many people have.
On the non-profit side it--the
compensation is relatively
modest and more or less
invariant with performance.
Take for instance,
Beinecke, there was a to do in
this same year because somebody
published--
their top salaries are also
published and her salary of
$252,000 was published,
and there was a populist outcry.
Now by private equity standards
that's not a lot of money.
Even by not--people on the
investment side in organizations
like this make three or four,
or ten times that,
but the general norm in
non-profits is--
how many--are there people here
who plan to become
non-profiteers?
Maybe?
Okay, well the one thing you
have to do is take a zero off
when you think about
compensation.
More or less it's--that's about
the ratio and its considerable,
so these are two very different
classes or organizations.
Here we have Fred Krupp of The
Natural Resources and Henry
Kravitz, and I'll bet not one of
you is in doubt about which is
which.
The pictures are--they get the
point across,
and why on earth would people
on this side be so interested in
participation from people on
this side?
Sasha, again.
Student:  If you ask
them to do something with the
business that makes them more
money ultimately,
then it's a good deal.
Prof: You nailed it,
and not one iota of direct
concern for the environment is
required to back that up.
Right?
So what's the biggest problem
about TXU?
Why is it--what--if you're
going to sit down and calculate
the risks from KKR and Texas
Pacific's point of view of
taking over this firm,
what would the main risks be?
They would be--would they be
that the technology will fail?
Would they be that consumer
demand for electric power will
suddenly go away?
Would they be that a new
entrant will come in;
a large new entrant will come
in, and begin to compete with
lower prices?
None of those things are
imaginable.
None of those are imaginable.
So why isn't this just a
license to print money?
The answer to that is that the
regulatory risk is substantial
at both the federal and state
levels,
much more substantial at the
federal level,
and that the process by which
the environmental groups would
in effect bless or kosher the
transaction is a way of limiting
political risk.
The EDF is all about the cause
of the environment and their
claim is that lobbying work
they've done in the years from
2001 to 2008 will diminish
diesel pollution by nearly 90%
by 2030,
and that's their business.
Their business is to get the
government to compel companies
to pollute less.
Fred Krupp at Davos in the year
of the case,
this is not in the case:
"The smartest companies
can see over the horizon and
anticipate consumer demands.
That's why the EDF has been
able to team with--
team up with ALCOA,
DuPont, Caterpillar,
GE, Duke Energy,
BP America, and others on a
plan that could cut greenhouse
gas emissions by 60% to 80% by
2050.
The plan is a jobs winner as
well as an environmental
winner."
So organizations like these are
brokers in which they cut deals
with businesses,
and the businesses they cut the
deals with are ones which have a
higher than average capacity to
withstand tighter regulation.
For example,
GE with Eco Imagination,
you've all heard of that?
If you watch television for any
period as long as an hour you
have been saturated with that
message, and why can GE do that?
Well why does it have to do it?
What's GE's long-term
reputation for environmental
pollution?
It is that they filled the
Hudson River with PCB's fifty
years ago,
and it's important to them to
get us off that topic and to
think of them in a different
way.
Second, they compete in Europe
for the manufacture of
electrically powered equipment,
and the regs in Europe are much
tighter than they are here from
an environmental point of view,
so they have developed a
technology to meet much higher
standards.
They've got it already in the
kit, and so from their point of
view, it is actually a corporate
strategy play to encourage the
feds to raise the bar.
Cap and trade,
I'm running out of time here,
cap and trade diagram--the
interesting side fact that cap
and trade in the EU basically
fizzled,
and it fizzled because the caps
that were put on the countries
were not low enough to make
people go out and buy credits.
They were set in a very gentle
political way and the market for
cap and trade depends on people
having to break the caps and buy
credits to make up for that,
and the caps were set so high
that it didn't produce the
desired effect.
I don't know why that slide is
there.
Now let's think about outcomes.
We've got on the vertical
dimension,
Green World,
and on the horizontal dimension
Green Paper,
and the four big quadrants--the
four quadrants of this space
define points we could think
about in looking at what the
risks and possibilities of this
are for these two classes of
organizations.
Down here, emissions are high
and profits are low is a
catastrophe on both dimensions
and the likelihood of both of
those things happening is very
small.
The story where you have both
high emissions and high profits,
this is the most worrying
category from the point of view
of the EDF.
This would constitute green
washing which has become a
really important epithet in the
politics of the environment,
where they're blessing
something which is a pretend
benefit to the environment,
and here is the disaster from
the point of view of KKR and
Texas Pacific,
where you have both low
emissions and low profits and do
you think KKR and Texas Pacific
enter into this relationship
fearing the risk that EDF and
The Natural Resources Defense
Fund will encourage the
imposition of standard so
Draconian that they can't make a
living?
Well no, they wouldn't have
chosen EDF as the lead agency if
EDF were of the same temperament
as the street theatre we saw in
the video.
They chose EDF because they
think they can cut a plausible
and constructive bargain with
them which leads,
not upper left but upper right
in the diagram,
for emissions decrease in a
substantial degree and profits
remain high.
This slide is in the--is from
the case and it's the full
inventory of exactions that Jim
Marston and EDF people consider
in looking at the case,
and they call it the blue sky
concessions,
because it's perfectly clear
they're not going to get all of
these,
but they want some of them and
they get some of them,
and they also get quite a lot
of symbolic buy in so that by
the current year 2009,
KKR is offering an investment
portfolio which it calls the
green portfolio,
and this consists not of
companies that are going to
devote themselves to producing
environmental products,
but rather to companies which
produce other products.
For example,
in Biomet, produce medical
devices but where they sign onto
the proposition that they will
make their production process
far greener than it was before,
so that I as an investor can
buy into the green fund,
and expect market rates of
return and think that on the
side I'm doing a little bit of
good for the environment.
[Video 46:37-47:08.]
Okay so--and they all went to
the beach and had a swell
afternoon.
The--okay so that's the last
case we're going to do,
except the one for your final,
and what I hope you'll do for
Wednesday is read the Finnegan
piece with some care.
He's a brilliant writer.
I got to know him personally
when he came to write about
violent kids in New Haven twenty
years ago,
and it's a beautifully written
piece and it's a compelling
story,
and also begin reviewing your
notes for the big picture flow
of the course.